y la fertilización in vitro es un
proceso mediante el cual los óvulos de
una mujer se fertilizan fuera del cuerpo
y luego se colocan dentro del cuerpo
para ayudarla a concebir
el sistema reproductor de una mujer
incluye la vagina
el cuello del útero
el útero
y las trompas de falopio
y los ovarios
durante el ciclo de menstruación mensual
uno de los ovarios libera un óvulo en un
proceso denominado ovulación
después de la ovulación el óvulo ingresa
a la trompa de falopio
una mujer tiene más probabilidades de
quedar embarazada si tiene relaciones
sexuales en los días justo antes durante
o después de la ovulación
durante este periodo un espermatozoide
del líquido reproductivo del hombre
denominado semen puede fertilizar el
óvulo dentro de la trompa de falopio
a medida que pasa por la trompa de
falopio el óvulo fertilizado ahora
denominado embrión pierde las células
exteriores que lo nutrían en el ovario
el embrión pasa de la trompa de falopio
al útero
en el útero el embrión elimina la capa
protectora exterior denominada zona
pelúcida en un proceso denominado
incubación en la zona la incubación en
la zona es necesaria para que el embrión
se implante en el tejido que cubre el
útero
durante la implantación se comienza a
crear la conexión entre la mujer y el
embrión
este órgano denominado placenta permite
que el oxígeno y los nutrientes pasen de
la madre al embrión
se puede realizar la fertilización in
vitro si una mujer tiene problemas para
quedar embarazada una condición
denominada infertilidad o también si una
mujer desea concebir un hijo sin una
pareja masculina
antes de la fertilización in vitro la
mujer recibirá medicamentos para la
fertilidad que hacen que maduren uno o
más óvulos en los ovarios
el hombre proveerá una muestra de semen
para recolectar el esperma más sano para
la fertilización
si la pareja masculina es completamente
infértil también conocido como estéril o
si la mujer no tiene una pareja
masculina se puede buscar un donante
para que proporciona el esperma para
este proceso
y la fertilización in vitro consta de
tres procedimientos principales
aspiración folicular
y fertilización
y transferencia del embrión
durante el primer procedimiento
denominado aspiración folicular se
recolectan los óvulos de los ovarios
al comienzo de este procedimiento se
inserta una sonda de ultrasonido en la
vagina de la mujer para que el médico
pueda ver los ovarios
dentro de los ovarios el médico busca a
los folículos cada folículo es una bolsa
llena de líquido que contiene un óvulo
y luego el médico introduce una aguja
larga y delgada a través de la pared
vaginal hasta el ovario
un dispositivo de aspiración conectado a
la aguja recolectar a varios óvulos
desde adentro de los folículos
durante la segunda parte de la
fertilización in vitro denominada
fertilización los óvulos recolectados
son llevados inmediatamente a un
laboratorio donde serán fertilizados
y la fertilización puede realizarse
mediante inseminación donde varios
esperma se mezclan con los óvulos más
sanos
o los óvulos pueden fertilizar se con el
esperma inyectado directamente en ellos
durante un proceso denominado inyección
intracitoplasmática de espermatozoides
los óvulos fertilizados también
denominados embriones serán monitoreados
entre tres y cinco días cuando comienzan
a crecer en este momento el laboratorio
puede crear un orificio en la zona p
lúdica que rodea a algunos embriones
este proceso denominado incubación
asistida ayudará a que los embriones se
implanten en el útero algunos de los
embriones se usarán enseguida para la
transferencia del embrión
y el resto se congelará y guardara para
su uso posterior si es necesario
y la tercera parte de la fertilización
in vitro se denomina transferencia del
embrión que se realiza entre 3 y 5 días
después de la fertilización durante la
transferencia del embrión se inserta una
herramienta denominada especuló en la
vagina de la mujer para que el médico
pueda ver el cuello del útero se cargará
una jeringa con líquido con uno o más
embriones incubados luego la jeringa se
colocará en un tubo largo y delgado
denominado catéter
el médico insertar el catéter en la
vagina
a través del cuello del útero hasta el
útero
una vez dentro del útero el médico
inyectar a los embriones
luego se retirarán el catéter y el
espéculo
es posible que la mujer deba permanecer
acostada durante aproximadamente 15
minutos